hijacking the news where I come from the  news is being hijacked no matter where  you turn there are characters where you  used to see experts journalism itself  has become a scripted reality show but  you know reality is a lot more complex  than that there are 50 billion shades of  gray it's not just good versus evil  us versus them black and white and in  countries like Russia China Turkey  people are told that it's that simple  the state media want them to believe  that and if you're a journalist there  and you try to get beyond that to get to  the truth you are facing scare tactics  intimidation and I wonder is that where  we're headed as well my responsibility  as a journalist is to get beyond the  smoke and mirrors to get to the truth  it's not just about being fair and  balanced or being neutral it's about  being truthful my name is Brent gaunt  and I work at DW  [Music]